[Music]
It's God. It's God. It's
God. It's God.
I never move. I am more important
[Applause]
than man.
So I just I want to ask you what is
gospel and who revealed the gospel?
Okay. So his question was what is the
gospel and then who revealed it? Okay.
So the gospel
you didn't go lower action. So the
gospel is um it's the message of the
Messiah that he is our salvation and
that salvation has come. Okay. Who
revealed it? Jesus Christ revealed it.
He let us know that the gospel of the
kingdom of God is here and at hand and
that salvation is at hand for the people
who will believe. So that's what the
gospel is and that's who revealed it. So
Jesus was the one that revealed the
gospel 100%. Yeah. Yes sir. Did Jesus
hear that? Yeah. He he says he came
preaching the gospel. No. Did he say he
did he Which gospel? What do you mean
which gospel? It's only the gospel. said
that he's the one he came here to to
teach the gospel. To preach the gospel.
Uh-huh. And to to to preach the gospel.
Yeah. Did he say that? Yeah. Okay. Okay.
So, because I am Muslim, we believe God
give
in we call gospel to Jesus. That is what
we believe.
But today is my first
time to hear from you that the the
gospel is revelation from Jesus. Yeah.
Yeah. And teaching from Jesus, not God.
Well, he is God in the Christian
paradigm. That's that's Jesus.
Why he say the word that you hear from
from me is not me but my father who sent
me. Well, he doesn't he doesn't exclude
himself, but he's what he's preaching is
in line with his father. the words that
he's with the father's words. So he's
doing is within the will of the father.
And that's why he says if you believe
you believe my words, these are not just
my my words but the father's words,
right? But he also says whoever hears my
words has life cuz my words give life.
My words give the living water, right?
And so that's why he says that. So it's
not he's not excluding himself. If if I
were to go with the Muslim view though,
like cuz I could grant it to you. I I
understand that you believe Allah gave
the revelation to Jesus and Jesus
preached it, right? I can I can
understand that. My problem is is that
um you guys say that we don't have what
Jesus was preaching. You know what I'm
saying? In in in the gospel in the Bible
that we have. And so I'm I go around and
I ask what is the justification for
that? Why do you guys say that what
Matthew, Mark, Luke, and John is wrote
is not the in jail is not the gospel?
Yeah, I get the get your
No. Yeah. Yeah. Come on, brother. No
problem. They don't come on problem.
Yeah. Yeah. You don't want to pay you,
do you? Come on. For you now, I'm coming
to you for you. Yes. If we say Jesus, we
mean God.
Jesus. Yeah. If you're talking for me,
we say God. When we say God, we mean
Jesus. Well, it depends. It depends on
the context. We believe God is triune.
He's multi-personal. So, we believe God
is the father. God is the son Jesus and
God is the holy spirit. So all three
persons are are identified as God. Okay.
So you you have to qualify it. You know
you got to be clear. So yeah. So you
believe Jesus can talk to God. God can
talk to Jesus. Yeah. I believe that the
father can speak to the son. The son can
speak to the spirit and vice versa. They
have an eternal uh fellowship and
communion with each other. So they can
talk to each other. Yeah. Jesus is all
knowing. Y his father is all knowing.
They can talk to each other. Yes. About
what? They just commune. They just
fellowship. About what? About their
their their love and communion. Yeah.
About what?
Knowing all knowing I don't know
anything. I say what you going to talk
about is knowing everything. Jesus is
Jesus also know everything. Uhhuh. Okay.
What you going to talk about? Anything.
Like example like what any um how they
love creation to say what? How they love
each other to say I love you. Yeah.
Yeah. Give this information to each
other. It's not just information. It's
an expression of love. Yeah. Because God
is love and the Bible says God is love.
For God to be love, there has to be a
relation that exists. But if they talk
to each other, can they be one? Yes.
They're one. What in essence? So notice
the category. They're one in essence.
Three persons, right? So they share the
same divine essence, the same properties
that make God God. That's what they are.
What they are. They are one God. And so
God, because he's love, it necessitates
that within the essence of God, he has
the greatest form of love without
depending on anything outside of
himself, which would require
relationship. So that means that within
the essence of God, there needs to be
relationship. And that's why we have the
father who eternally begins the son and
the father eternally spirates the spirit
and they commune and fellowship with
each other from eternity past. They can
talk to each other. They can send each
other. Yes, they can send each other.
Yeah, they can divide themselves. Not
divide. That's not That's not division.
If I can send you, you are not part of
I'm not I'm not we're not we don't have
the same essence. Yeah. God sends Jesus.
Yeah. So So another another person can
send another person. Yes. For that mean
they are different. If he send they're
just they're different persons. Yeah.
They're different person. Yes. So father
one God different person. Father is not
Jesus. Father is not the same person as
the son. Jesus is not the father. He's
not the same person as the father. He's
not. Well Jesus is God. Father is God.
Yeah. They're the same one God. So
notice the categories what for example.
So for example, um because here's the
categories we're talking about being or
what you are, right? Like for example,
you are a human being, right? That's
what you are versus who you are. The
person, right? You're Dennis. I'm a
human being as well. I'm Avery. However,
you and I were two different human
beings, right? We're we're separated.
We're divided. Right? With God, he's one
being. Okay? Within the one being of
God, there exists three persons. The
father Yeah. three persons and one
essence. the Father, the Son, and the
Holy Spirit. Just hold on a second. So,
when we're having this conversation
about the nature of God, what a lot of
Muslims do, you guys conflate the
categories. You guys take being as if
it's the same as personhood when it's
not. Like, for example, you would agree
that a rock has being, right? It has a
state of existence, right? Would you say
that a rock is a person, though? Right?
So, a rock is a being, but it's not a
person. So, there's a difference between
being and personhood. Right? Now what
about humans? You would agree that a
human is a being, right? How many
persons is a human being? One person.
One person. Okay. So every one human
being is one person. How many human
beings are there? It's like there's a
lot, right? So there's many. Okay. Now
when we get to God, the divine being.
How many divine beings are there? One.
Just one. So there's one divine being
and then we're saying that he's three
persons. So three persons, one divine
being. Two different categories. Three.
Three person, one human being. Yeah.
Three persons, one divine being. One
divine being. Yeah. Can you can you show
that show me that in your Bible? You
want those in that in that exact words?
Yes. I want to know because you tell me
now. I don't know whether it's in the
Bible or you are telling me. Can you
show me that where Jesus said that?
Okay. Jesus should the best person to
teach us that is Jesus, isn't it? Yeah.
Because the gospel come from Jesus
himself, isn't it? Yeah. Yeah. Show me
that. So, but before I do that, I want
to make sure I I get you what you're
asking. I want to know if you telling me
the right thing. I got you. So are you
asking where Jesus says in his own words
explicitly that God is one divine being
and who exists as three persons? Yeah.
If you don't show me that and then you
can tell me what make you say that can
be something you can take that from
Jesus teaching even he doesn't say that
literally. Okay. Gotcha. Okay. Show me
that. Yeah. Okay. So we we won't have
those exact words. However, I can show
you from the teachings of Jesus and the
prophets that the father is God, the
holy spirit is God and um that the son
is God. Jesus and there's one God. Show
me. So I can show you that. Okay. All
right. Cool. Say that. Yeah. Well, I'm
I'm going to show you that Jesus claimed
to be God. No. Jesus gospel. Show me
reveal. Show Yeah. I'm going to show
you. Okay. For All right. So, for
example, I'm going to show
you that Jesus the father is is God. The
son is God. The Holy Spirit is God.
Yeah. Let me show you that. All right.
Zoom
in. All right. Just so just just so
before I show you this, who would you
say is the first and the last?
What? The first and the last. You you
familiar with that title of God?
Brother, before we go there, you said
you going to show I know. I am. I'm
about to show you that Jesus is God.
Jesus is God. I am. I'm about to show
you all of this. Holy Spirit is God. I
know. I'm about to show you this. So I'm
trying to lay out the foundation. Who
Who is the first and the last? The first
and last God. Very good. So the first
and the last is God. Very good. When we
go to the New
Testament, we see that Jesus claims to
be the first and the last. Okay? The
alpha and omega, the beginning and the
end. So this what it says. It says,
excuse me, ya, stop
cheating. Stop cheating. Ya. So
Revelation 11:17, it says, "When I saw
him, I fell at his feet as though dead."
So this is John talking. But he laid his
right hand on me, saying, "Fear not. I
am the first and the last. So Jesus here
claims to be God. Can we agree with that
so far? Yeah. Yeah. Okay, good. So we
got that Jesus claims to be God. You
already agree that the father is God. Do
I have to show you the father? Yeah. No,
no problem. I agree that the father in
the book of Isaiah is I am first and
last. Okay, good. What What does mean
you finish? I want to see what you All
right. So we got that. We already know
the father is God. We got that the son
is God, right? That's where we at. So
now you need to see that the spirit is
God. Right? If Jesus say he's the first
and then he say he's the first. He's the
first and the last. Yes. That mean to
you that he's is God because he say
that. Correct. But he never he's
claiming to be God. Yes. Because he say
he's the first and then he say he's the
last. Yeah. Okay. So and for you because
of Jesus for for both of us. You believe
that God is God is honest. Yeah. We
believe God is honest. Honest is good.
Yeah, I can say you are a good man as
well. Yeah. Yeah. I don't I don't mean
that you are. Okay. Good. I'm good.
Yeah. And Jesus say he's the first.
Yeah. God also say the he say God say
he's the first and the last. Is the
father say or god? God. God say he's the
first and the last. Okay. Now the spirit
now. Okay. Where the spirit. All right.
So I I want to touch on your point that
you said. Okay. So his point was, you
know, um, you know, uh, if you say if
you get a title that God has, you know,
it doesn't necessarily mean that you're
God, right? Like you can say that you're
good. I say that God is good. That
doesn't mean you're God because you're
you I say that you're good. I'm not
calling you God, right? However, there
are titles and names that belong to God
alone. Would you agree? Like you can't
go to another person and say you're the
most merciful, right? You can't go to a
person and say that you're the most
loving or uh uh the judge of the earth
or stuff like this or the first and the
last. Right? These are titles and names
for God alone. Would you agree? Okay.
So, this right here is a title that
Jesus claims for himself that belongs to
God alone. So, he's claiming to be God
here. He's not claiming just a generic
title. He's claiming a title of God
himself. I get that. I get your point
because see what if you go to revelation
when Jesus was on earth that one was the
best place should have like teach us but
this one now is by vision or by dream
that was revealed to John was come to
John this one now you are reading
there's nothing wrong with that yes I'm
so there's no witness like Jesus now
what he's teaching everybody is here and
then even he said father the job that
you sent me to do I have accomplished So
no more, no less. But after saying this
one, this revelation came. Yeah. Yeah.
But hold on. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Just just
to give a clarification. He does tell
them that there's many things he has
left to say to them, but they can't
handle it yet. Right. He said that he's
not the one that will will say again. I
said, I have many things to tell you.
Cannot bear them now. But it's not his
job. The things that he didn't say, it's
not his job to say that again. But it'll
be it'll be by the spirit that he
declares this to them. So through so
through the spirit Jesus will be
revealing more things. Yes. So John is
caught up in the spirit here. He says
whatever the spirit shall hear shall
tell you. Yeah. Whatever he hear. Yeah.
He says that he's declaring to you what
is mine. Yeah. For whatever he hear.
Yeah. He's hearing from who? From him.
From Jesus. He's Yeah. Jesus is hearing
from who? No. The Holy Spirit is hearing
from Jesus. But Jesus also is hearing
and Jesus heard from the father. Uh
Jesus also hearing from the father.
Yeah. problem with God then this is the
problem you talking about what's the
problem all of them hearing from God
from the father but father is not
hearing from them that's the one
information no it's not it's not
information it's when it's basically the
go-ahhead to reveal certain things right
so they do things at the father's will
in order which they share with them so
that that doesn't take them from being
god you mean father is the boss no
problem there's a hierarchy father is
the boss they serve the father yes they
serve the father yeah even though they
have the same nature they serve the
Father. Yes. So God that mean they are
also God. They have the same nature as
the father. They also go. Yes. They have
the same nature as the father. God is
more than one. More than one. More than
one. He's more than one. I think brother
you're doing again. You're conflating
the categories. What? What do I say?
He's more than one. What? Yeah. More
than one what? Yeah. No no no. What he
saying? When he say I'm talking about my
point. When I when I say God is more
than one. More than one. Say God is more
than one. Did you say more than one?
What? No. Did you say God is more than
one? Brother, you're not listening,
brother. No. No. No. Just I want to
Okay, I'll repeat it again. Did you say
so? There's there's category. No, you
said that. I said you're saying that I'm
saying God is more than one. But if I'm
saying God is more than
one, the Holy Spirit. So there's three.
Hold on. Let me Yeah. Yeah. Respect.
You're not You're disrespecting the
conversation right now. Block me.
Come on.
Here. You cannot block me. I know. I
can't block it here.
So we broke down the categories. Okay. I
don't know why we have to backtrack. The
category is being. There's one being,
one God, three persons. Okay, two
different categories. So when I say that
the father, son, and holy spirit
together and they're distinct from each
other in personhood, but they are the
same in their being. Okay? So do don't
conflate the categories. When I say that
the son and the spirit hear from the
father, don't think that I'm saying that
the son and the spirit are hearing from
a different being than them. They're the
same nature, same being different
person. Get that because now what I
don't understand, you say before the
gospel is teaching from Jesus. He said
that. Yeah. Now he's saying that God is
the one that talking to Jesus. Did Did
he say that? He said that Holy Spirit
when we was talking of Holy Spirit I
told you
that whatever the Holy Spirit
hear that Holy Spirit is hearing from
father. No no no from Jesus. Oh from
Jesus. Yes. And then Jesus is hearing
from Jesus heard from the father.
Is revelation for for who? Jesus or the
father. Both. It's not either or. It's
both. So the the gospel come from Jesus.
The teaching comes from Jesus and the
father. It's from both. Yes. Jesus said
it's not my word. What I'm saying it's
he says it is. He literally says what
you what you confusing. Yeah. Stop
interrupting, brother. Let us talk, bro.
Look.
Yeah. You're lying. You're disrespecting
the conversation. You You could You
could say that, but you're disrespecting
the conversation. We are all You're
interrupting the conversation, bro. I am
interrupting. You had your turn. I g I
gave you your turn. You're interrupting
the
conversation. You're you're interrupting
the conversation. Yay. King of kings,
lord of lords. So notice I gave you your
respect and now you're manifesting. Now
you're manifesting approachable life.
I'm losing my respect. You're losing my
respect. The father can continue. Is the
only true God. The father according to
Jesus. I thank you. Ya. That's enough.
That's enough. That's enough. That's
enough. We're talking to somebody else,
bro. Okay. Thank you. I'm going to give
you back. Thank you. I'm going to cook
with you. So now, so Jesus Jesus was
teaching the gospel. Was teaching people
the gospel? Yes. In in which language?
Uh Hebrew, Greek, and Aramaic. Aramaic.
He was teaching people in Greek. Greek.
Hebrew and Aramaic. Did he say that?
Well, he was speaking to Roman
centurions who spoke Greek. So if he
something happen, you can talk to them
on the gospel. I don't mean like you can
talk to me now in English or in
different language. Yeah. But your
teaching will be like one language. You
get my point? No. Why? So now the
question is one wait was you mean the
angel that Jesus was teaching how many
language? Three. Three languages. Three.
Which one? He So lit literally in the
gospel you have him reading in Hebrew
the the Isaiah scroll. You have him
speaking Aramaic and then you also have
him speaking to Roman centurions who
spoke Greek. They didn't speak Aramaic
or Hebrew. They're they're they're
Romans, right? They're Roman rulers and
soldiers. So you mean if Jesus talked to
the like if Jesus talked to Romans, that
mean that is the part of that means that
that means he's speak Yeah. Well, yeah.
That is the part of Yes. Because what he
said is in the end what he said the
gospel. Look, he was even teaching them
even he even said for example about a
Roman centurion when he spoke to them
and gave them the gospel. He said
there's not going to be any I haven't
seen anyone with as much faith in all of
Israel as this gentile as this Roman
centurion and he's communicating this
with him. So he has to understand it
speaking Greek that is a part of
like what he's saying what he what are
you doing? So like we look at Jesus,
what he's saying, what he's doing, what
happened. Is that what you call in jail?
Yes, that's the gospel. What Jesus did
and what he said is the gospel. Simple.
That's the in jail. But why? I think in
the Bible they say Jesus went to
Galilee. He was preaching the gospel.
Yes. Which gospel was it? The of the
kingdom of God about about of the
kingdom of God. That that he's the son
who came to save the world. Yeah. And
they need to repent and believe the
gospel. Believe in him. So, so that
gospel is how many book? Um, it's it's
four accounts. Four accounts. Yep. So,
it's one gospel. It's usually called the
four-fold gospel in the early church.
So, you got four accounts of the gospel
of Jesus, right? Matthew, Mark, Luke,
and John, they wrote the accounts of the
gospel of Jesus. But why is not the same
there? It is the same thing. What are
you talking about? Why you can It's not
the same. The other guy I am. When we
read the John before Abraham, I am. And
then I am the way. I am. You cannot find
that in Matthew. You cannot find Luke. I
get what you're saying. There's a lot of
different things. Yeah. They give they
give the a different They're giving a
different account of the gospel to write
like dict if we all there our gospels
will be the same. Why is not the same?
Well, because you have these different
witnesses who are giving the account of
the gospel. They give a different
account, but it's the same gospel. It
doesn't if if if John has something that
Mark didn't write down or Matthew has
something that Luke didn't record, that
doesn't change the gospel. We see the
gospel in its full picture. We can
harmonize all four accounts and we see
what the gospel is. You get what I'm
saying? So, but if you read the Bible,
there's a red red letter Bible. You see
that? You know that in some editions?
Yeah. Uh the the black one come from
who? It depends on what uh who published
that, bro. Yeah. The black No, no. Go
open Luke 1 verse 1-4. That one come
from who? From the eyewitnesses. From
the eyewitnesses. Why that one? word is
part of the gospel as well because it's
the gospel.
The word that come from he said that the
what Jesus what Jesus said and did is
the gospel. So Luke Luke wrote it down.
That one doesn't come from Jesus. It it
does because the open well he literally
goes to the eyewitnesses. That's what he
says, right? He said he went to the
eyewitnesses. That one come from him. He
said well he said I'm I'm writing down
an orderly account based off what the
eyewitnesses the disciples that come
from have told me. That one come from
who? What do you mean? From Luke, isn't
it? What you told me now? Yeah. So Luke
is writing an account of the gospel of
Jesus. What you told me now? Why that
one is part of the gospel? Jesus didn't
teach that. The I the eyewitness deliver
this one to me. I go I do my I do this
in brother Dennis. What did I say the
gospel here? What? Hold on. Please don't
stop the gospel. You need to
have so it's what Jesus did and what he
taught
right when Luke says I am writing an
orderly account of the gospel that I got
from the eyewitnesses. That's where he
got it from. So he's writing the gospel.
Yeah, I get now. I get now what that
that particular word doesn't come from
Jesus, isn't it? No, that's what Luke's
saying. Yeah, that but why word is
inside the gospel? Because he's inspired
by the Holy Spirit. So right now he
never said he said that with Luke
doesn't have Luke doesn't have to say
that. Let me tell you let me tell you
what Paul says this. Paul says that all
scripture is God breathed and and and
originated from the Holy Spirit. And
Paul literally quotes Luke's gospel and
calls it scripture. See so what Luke is
writing down when he's writing down the
gospel of Jesus inspired by uh inspired
by the Holy Spirit. get the account.
Brother, I want to go one by one. I'm
talking of Yeah, but you're not
listening. No, I'm listening. You say
Paul to answer
uh what I say about Luke. Oh, that all
scriptures God breathe, right? I don't
need Paul to help here. So, Luke should
help him. I'm using No, no, no. Okay.
It's like it's it's like if I do this
like I give you example like I give you
if if I were to ask you for example if I
ask you where in the Quran does it say
that that where does it in the Quran
does Muhammad say Gabriel came to me?
Where is where does Muhammad say that in
the Quran? Would you be able to show me
that? No. No. No. No. No problem. No
problem. I can't. You see how it's like
a double standard. It's not like that.
It's not like that. But you should have
said did Muhammad say that angel come to
him come to him? That will be your
question. No it shouldn't cuz that's not
what you're asking me. You're asking me.
You're saying Luke should say that what
he's receiving is from the Holy Spirit
to to interview the
eyewitness. So Muhammad should So
Muhammad should say that Gabriel came to
me in the cave and inspired me to recite
the verses. Yeah. If Muhammed say that
did Muhammad say that? Yeah. Muhammed
said that come to him in the cave. Did
he say that? Yeah. Did he say that in
the Quran? To say what? Did he say that
Gabriel came to me in the cave and gave
me the Quran? Yeah. No. No. It doesn't.
Quran was revealed by who? Who revealed
the Quran? Allah. Do you see the devil?
Do you see the double standard? No, no,
no. We I'm talking of Luke here. What is
not the Quran? I'm not talking what is
not inside the Quran. What is not I'm
not talking that I'm not talking to you
what is outside of the Bible. I'm
talking to you what is inside the Bible.
I know. No. I know what's inside. I
know. I know what you're saying. So now
no, wait, wait, wait. You cannot say
what is what is not inside Quran using
that thinking that you have answered my
question. It's not like that. Me I'm
talking to you. what is in the Bible. So
now the Bible is the teaching of Jesus.
Any teaching that is there doesn't come
from Jesus is not part of the gospel.
No, not not just that. Not just that as
well. So we can be another teaching can
be that doesn't come from the Holy
Spirit. Remember the remember he says
they had many things to reveal to them
but they couldn't handle it. But the
Holy Spirit is going to come and teach
them, right? And they're going to
remember the words of Jesus and then
understand them. And then also the Holy
Spirit is going to teach them things,
right? So when they're writing, they're
inspired by the Holy Spirit. So even
when Luke says, "Hey guys, what I'm
writing is an orderly account that I got
from the eyewitnesses to write an
orderly account on the gospel." The Holy
Spirit inspired him to do so.
You understand? Can I ask you a
question? You don't get that. How's that
not clear? Can I ask a question? No.
Yeah. Yeah. I'm talking to him. And
yeah, yeah. I
said it talk about about So do you
believe that the gospel we have is The
gospel of Jesus and people coming out of
the grave and wander around people dead
people none of the other gospel mention
it is that fact or fiction I give you
this you give to that person so it come
from
me give that so so basically when the
Quran is saying that they have the
gospel right and it confirms the gospel
in Muhammad's time said they have the
gospel yes say that The the Quran says
the Quran says that they have the
gospel. They have the show me. Yeah.
Yeah. I I got
you. Why? Why he's showing you guys the
gospel mean here? The gospel mean here
the commandment the commandment the
commandment of the law. The commandment
of the law. While I I repeat myself.
You're being disrespectful. You're being
disrespectful. People coming out of the
grave and walk. You had your time, bro.
Stop interrupting the conversation bro
other gospel there's no mention for it
the is for and not truth and not even
eyewitness why you why you forsaken yeah
yeah do you mind if I finish my
conversation I'm not going okay I'm not
saying go but let me finish my
conversation okay all right so this is
chapter 7 verse 157 it says those who
follow the messenger the prophet who can
neither read nor write whom they will
find described in the Torah and the
gospel with them, right? He will enjoin
them what what is good and what is right
and so on and so forth. But basically,
so the important relevant part is that
the gospel is with them. They have it in
Muhammad's time. Okay? The law of
Moses because Jesus come in the law of
Moses. So Jesus was talking about what
he has. He come in the law of Moses and
law of Moses was with them and he was
sent. So they they have what I'm they
have what I'm reading. They have the
Bible.
They have I cannot see that one here to
say they have gospel. Yeah. I cannot see
that. Look, it says in and the Torah and
the gospel with them. Yeah. With them.
That where is that? Those who follow
Yes. Let me go like that.
Sorry. Oh, let me He's right. He's
right. What he's saying is right. Those
who follow the messenger the prophet who
can neither I say is the truth. I'm not
going to whom they will find described.
Mhm. In their book. Yeah. In the gospel.
Yeah. In the gospel. With them. Where is
it? With with them. Yeah. So they can
find Muhammad mentioned in their book.
Yeah. The book that they have. Yeah.
Which is the Torah and Gospel. Yeah.
Yeah. Torah and Gospel that they have.
They can find Muhammad in it. Mhm. So it
says they have the gospel.
Is that mean they have the gospel? Yeah.
It literally says it. It literally said
they have the gospel. So the gospel is
with them, you know. So they have what
I'm reading. So basically in what I'm
reading, I should be able to find
Muhammad mentioned in it according to
the Quran. Now if I can't find Muhammad
mentioned in the gospel, then that means
that the Quran is making a false claim.
Right? If he's not in there, then
Muhammad's a false prophet and Islam is
false. So for you to if the Bible say to
mention Muhammad for you have to be
mentioned by name or description. It it
could be by name or description. Either
one, you know, I I'll I'll grant
description, right? If his description
is found in the in the gospel, then I
have to believe Muhammad's a messenger.
I do. I'll be compelled to it. That's my
scripture, you know. But when if Jesus
say if
ignore send me,
I have many things to tell you, but you
cannot bear them now. Yes. You
understand? And Jesus said that he said
that he will send there. You said that
the father will send you another
comforter. The Holy Spirit. Another one.
Another one. Yeah. The Holy Spirit.
Yeah. Another comforter. Yeah. Holy
Spirit. Yeah. Father will send you.
Yeah. Yeah. But if Quran say he was
revealed by angel Gabriel Uhhuh. Quran
said that like the Holy Spirit was
revealed to what we do. Um okay. Um my
my point is is that when he says that
the Holy Spirit is going to come to the
disciples. Okay. So he's going to come.
Did he say Did he say he will come to
the disciples? Yes. So where's that one?
Yeah, I got you. So this is in
John chapter, we can start at verse 13
cuz this is when the conversation
starts. Okay. Yeah. Yeah. So in John 13
um just wait for it to load
up anytime guys. just uh having
technical difficulties,
you know. It was working fast a little
second ago. Yeah. I don't know what
happened to it. Come on, man.
All of a sudden, I don't want to.
Thank you,
man. You guys are so kind. He have he
have Okay, so John
13. Let's see. You're in the context
here. Uhuh. Uhuh.
Uhuh. Rosie lad aside.
Okay. All right. So, in the context here
now, before the feast of the Passover,
when Jesus knew the hour had come to
depart out of this world, out of this
world to the father, having loved his
own who were in the world, he loved them
to the end. I'm talking about his
disciples. During supper, when the devil
had already put into the heart of Judas,
a scariot, Simon's son, to betray him,
Jesus, knowing that the father had given
all things into his hands, and that he
had come from God, and was going back to
God, rose from supper. He laid aside his
outer garments, the towel, and he began
to wash their feet. Just the sake of
time, I'll just skip that. He began to
wash their feet. So, he's with the
disciples, and he's washing the feet of
the disciples. Okay? So then you see
Peter's there, you know, he's like, "Why
are you doing this?" And, you know, yada
yada yada. And he told him, right, "Back
away from me, shall." So then he says,
you know, he talks about how one of you
guys are going to betray me. Okay? And
it's going to be Judas, obviously.
Right? So one of his disciples spoke
whom Jesus loved. Is it me? Is is it
going to be me? yada yada yada. Right?
He keeps going. Um let's see here. Let's
talk about the new commandment. He says,
uh, "A new commandment I give you that
you love one another as I have loved
you. You are also to love one another.
By this all people will know that you
are my disciples if if you love one
another. Right. And so we continue. We
go to the next chapter. In the next
chapter, he's continuing the
conversation. Chapter 14. Yep. Chapter
14. And this is when he talks about the
next comforter to come. Okay. So he says
about the comforter talking to his
disciples. He
says, "If you love me, you will keep my
commandments and I will ask the father
and he will give you another helper to
be with you forever." Right? Another
another two. Yes. He's one. Who was the
who was? Jesus. So the one that have to
come have to be human being there. No,
it doesn't have to be human being. No,
it doesn't. No, it doesn't have to be a
human being. Just another help. They can
carry on. Carry on. I'm going to show
you that it's not a human being. For
example,
to be with you forever one. So the
helpers coming to the disciples, he
says, right? Yeah. Okay, that's number
one. So it can't be Muhammad. It comes
to the disciples, right? Here's detail
number two. It says um to be with you
forever. Yeah. Yeah. We heard that.
Carry on. Carry on. Right. So he says
the helper will be with you forever.
Carry on. Please with you forever. I'm
very interested. Carry on. Wait.
Disciples first.
Come on. for disciple only or for
everybody. Everybody but specifically
the disciples first. Okay. The that holy
spirit that the disciple have you have
the same holy spirit of you. Yes. Yes.
That's teaching you what Jesus said.
Yes. 100%. Okay. So look carry on carry
on reading. So he says to be with you
forever even the spirit of truth whom
the world can't receive because it
neither sees him or knows him. So the
world can't see the spirit of truth and
it doesn't know him. People saw
Muhammad, right? He was able to be seen.
He was visible. The spirit of truth
coming is invisible. So it's showing you
that he's not a human being. And then we
don't know him. The world doesn't know
him. But watch this. But it says, "But
you know him, the disciples." So the
disciples know the Holy Spirit. Yeah.
Because he dwells with you. Because he's
with Jesus. The Holy Spirit descended on
Jesus. It will dwell with them or he's
dwelling with them. He's he's dwelling
with them now. So he's with them now.
He's with them now. If I don't go, he
will not come. I'll tell you why. Okay.
Listen. So remember remember that the
baptism, right? Yeah. If I don't go, he
will not come. He didn't go and receive
the Holy Spirit. Let me explain that.
Okay. So at Jesus's baptism, the Holy
Spirit came down and dwelt on Jesus. So
wherever you see Jesus in his earthly
ministry, the Holy Spirit is present as
well. He's helping him. Yep. Okay. So
you have Jesus and the Holy Spirit
there. So whenever the disciples are in
the presence of the of Jesus, they are
also with the Holy Spirit. Okay? When
Jesus leaves, the Holy Spirit goes with
him. Thank God. That's what And that's
why that's why when Jesus says, "When I
go away," he says, "I will send him the
Holy Spirit is coming back." So this
time at first they're with him. Right.
Back. Yes. Yeah. Absolutely. True spirit
now. So that mean
okay no problem no wait wait wait first
they have holy spirit he say
back okay sister if I don't go he will
not come that is one spirit explain yeah
brother listen please you want to
come take yeah this man is this is it's
painful for the crowd brother I want if
I don't go he will not come but that
mean as long as he's here he's not with
them am I correct No, you are. Did you
hear Did you hear what I said?
Okay. Look, he says that he dwells with
you now, right? Yeah. He's with them.
Okay. Now, he says, "And will be in
you." So, not only will they be with the
Holy Spirit, but when he comes, he will
be in them. The Holy Spirit will be
inside of them. Showing you this isn't a
human being, right? Okay. So, it's not a
human being. It's a spirit.
And now, and now, by the way, when it
says will be in you, this is future,
right? Will be is in the future tense.
So, he dwells with them now, but he's
not in them yet. When he comes again,
this time he will be in them. Make
sense?
Dwelling with with them. What does it
means that he they're they're in the
presence. They they're they're in his
presence. Like, I'm dwelling with you
now. We're together, you know? So the
Holy Spirit is with them but he's not in
them. When he comes back he will be in
them this time. If I don't go he will
not
come say he will be in you not. If I
don't go this spirit will not come. So
this is what we have. I understand. I I
understand what you're saying. So this
is what we have. Put two and two
together. Put two together. If he's with
them already, yeah, that means that when
Jesus goes, the Holy Spirit goes with
him and then he sends him
back. That's what you do when you put
two together. Yeah. Jesus, if Jesus go,
Jesus will go with them. But what we
reading now, Jesus said that the
Okay. All right. You're welcome. Take
care, bro. Then Jesus saying to them
that the spirit is dwelling with them.
That is the present. Now when Jesus was
saying this that is the present. Yeah.
Is who present? Yes. The present. And
the presence. Yes. Yeah. That is 14.
Yeah. Chapter 14. Yeah. 16. If I don't
go, he will not come. So that mean that
is the problem I'm facing. If I don't go
is spiritual, he will not come. That
mean that spirit is not there. Okay.
Yes. He's talking of his if if I don't
go. Let me let me let me I don't go
Let me give an example. Let me give an
example. Let's say um let's say let's
say it's okay. Let's say I'm with you
now, right?
Let's let's try this. Let's try this.
This one is okay. Let's let's let's try
this. Let's say I'm with you, right?
Okay. Wherever you go, I'm with you. I'm
with Dennis. Hey, God. Logic is always
with Dennis wherever he goes. Okay. And
then you tell the crowd that um that
that you're about to go away. Okay. I go
with you wherever you go. I'm stuck to
you wherever you go. Okay. Now you say
that if I don't go away, if I don't go
away, God logic will not come to you.
But if I go, I will send him. Okay. Does
that mean that I wasn't already here
when you were here? No. Right. So I was
here already, but then I left when you
left and then you sent me back, right?
He's with me and he's with them. He's
two things different. All right. If he's
with me, he's with them. Two things
different. Are you with them? Yes. No,
you are with me. Then you are helping
me. You are not helping them now. No
worries. But if you help them, the
minute change. I got you. So am I. Am I
Wait. The Holy Spirit have to Dennis.
Follow it. You have a job to do. Follow
it. Okay. Let's say you're the one
teaching them. I'm not teaching them.
I'm helping you teach. I'm reading the
book for you. I'm handing you the
pamphlets or the pen. I'm helping you
and you are teaching them. Right. Are we
with them? Are we with everyone? Yeah,
we are. We are. Okay. Now, let's say you
leave. Yeah. I'm stuck with you. If you
leave, I leave, too, right? So, I'm no
longer with them. Yeah. Okay. But you
can send me back to them if you want,
right? Yeah. Yeah. I'm listening to you.
Okay. So, if you go, you can still send
me. It doesn't mean that I wasn't there
with you at the time you was there with
them, but you could send me back. How's
that hard?
I get I get you. I get you. It's not
simple. It's not simple. This one is
your neighbor. Yes, it's simple. But no
problem, brother. Thank you for your
help. I like you. Thank you. I like you
too, man.
Oh, yeah.
So, thank you, man. This was a good
conversation, man. Appreciate it. Yeah.
God bless you, bro.
So guys, to wrap up to wrap up,
this is a this is a continuous problem
that the Muslims have. Okay? Because
they have to go back to the gospel.
Okay? And going back to the gospel, it
demonstrates that the Quran cannot
stand. Because the the very thing it
says that it's standing on rips it from
under its feet. When we go to the
gospel, we don't find Muhammad. We don't
find his description. We don't find
anything. And if he's not in there, then
the Quran is false.
Simple as that.
Okay. Can I come in? No.
No. It's God. It's God.
[Music]